à quelle vitesse faut-il rouvrir
l'économie jean françois perrault est
notre invité ce soir économiste en chef
de la scotia à toronto bonsoir monsieur
perrault bonsoir
quels sont vos observations sur cet
enjeu de réouverture de l'économie
comment devrait-on procédé selon vous
c'est qu'il est clair que là je connais
peu et très important si on regarde la
prévision pour le québec on anticipe une
baisse d'activité en mai autour de 9%
compte c'est la même chose pour le
canada ont ensemble
donc il est clair et les mesures qu'on a
mises en place pour contrôler la
progression du virus ont un coût très
important dans il ya une prestation
réussie de trouver une façon de nourrir
l'économie tout en me lisant la
possibilité qu'une ré l'occurrence du
virus
et c'est là l'enjeu c'est que les
ventres les pressions économiques
évidemment les mesures ont jugé
nécessaire de moi qui vous autorise t
médical nécessaire mais ne faut pas
aller trop vite mais il faut rouvrir
l'économie selon vous il faut il faut
essayer ce qui se passe où il ya une
différence de philosophie d'action vue
relativement ternes quand vous l'avez
mentionné les gens qui adorent plutôt
tendance à mettre de l'emphase sur
l'aspect santé publique de la
problématique de s'assurer vraiment
qu'on a levé 200 contrôleurs ou s'agit
il est beaucoup plus de poids du mode
d'administration train il beaucoup plus
de poids sur la réouverture de
l'économie peu importe un peu là ce qui
se passait au niveau de la santé piloté
le risque si on si les américains font
ce qu'ils font c'est que évidemment la
crise qu'on attend on attend au 3ème
trimestre après trimestre la reprise
attendue en bio zermati d'années lorsque
on est où l'économie parce qu'on va se
retrouver ça va prendre combien de temps
selon vous à rouvrir et a retrouvé la
pleine activité de l'économie canadienne
pas très longtemps donc il ya deux
interventions la première c'est
qu'évidemment dans la dynamique on a
ignoré d'activité connexion après on a
su de l'année l'accélération devient
moitié de l'année mais ça veut pas dire
que l'accélération à faire en sorte
qu'on va se retrouver au niveau
d'activité précédent d'après nos
prévisions on anticipe qu on veut
tourner au niveau d'activité qu'on
observait en fin 2010 mais seulement
quand début 2010 malgré des taux de
croissance très important c'est quand
même un gros bourg non payant noter qu'à
l'économie canadienne baisse de 40 ou 50
points de pourcentage en un trimestre
sont créés énormément t'es retrouvé donc
si j'ai bien compris ce que vous avez
dit là on va retrouver seulement au
début de 2022 le niveau que nous avions
à la fin de 2019 si ça c'est sa prison
parlement européen allez-y on espère
évidemment avoir tordu mais ceci est en
dynamique il n'y a pas eu quand même
quand même pas mal de questions à la
baisse sur l'économie nationale pourrait
évidemment des risques à la baisse sur
l'activité en deuxième moitié d'année si
on n'arrive pas à me parlant de
l'inflation chute de l'inflation en mars
puis la banque du canada prévoyait
récemment un taux d'inflation même à 0%
est ce qu'on s'en va vers une situation
de baisse des prix de déflation
il est clair qu'au niveau au niveau de
l'inflation totale
l'ipc total comme l'avait indiqué le
prix du pétrole joue un rôle très
important et donc sur marie la baisse du
prix du pétrole qu'on observait avec
l'augmentation de l'écart de production
donc la faiblesse de l'économie actuelle
on anticipe une baisse du niveau des
prix au canada
4ème trimestre du 1er trimestre
ça veut pas dire que c'est une situation
de déflation si on si on extrait un peu
l'élément du pit super pole de sa regard
de l'inflation tendancielle
donc on attire tant l'amélioration ou
déroule autour de points 56 points c'est
beaucoup plus que la banque
mais quand même temps même un niveau
relativement élevé quand on concède mais
la baisse brutale du prix du pétrole
est ce que si je vous comprends bien ce
n'est pas un signe généralisée de
déflation pas encore non 5,5 généralisée
économique est clair c'est un signe d'un
peu de ma gestion de la vraiment bizarre
dans ce marché là qui était asocial de
demandes qu'on observait les producteurs
ont augmenté la production pétrole donc
c'est ce qui se fait qu'une fois mais ça
fait en sorte qu'on se retrouve dans une
situation qui fait quoi là dès ses 17
ans incroyable dans les dingues bonjour
mais cette saison c'est un artefact la
situation actuelle s'est récemment les
pressions déflationnistes
on a souvent vu au fil du temps
l'évolution du dollar canadien en
fonction du prix du pétrole
oui le pétrole a chuté beaucoup au cours
des dernières semaines
le dollar canadien est passé de 75 76 77
on a l'impression que le dollar canadien
résiste à la chute du pétrole finalement
pourquoi il ya des choses qui se passent
évidemment le motif de ce pétrole avec
derniers jours est pas représentatif du
marché du coton en général donc le fait
que le prix ce pétrole américain est
passé - quand quelque chose de l'ordre
du jour les gens perçu sur comme étant
un seuil de 90 ans paraît effectivement
aujourd'hui on se retrouve avec un prix
du pétrole américain qui peut tourner à
canon dans les grandes écoles par contre
dans il ya un aspect il ya un élément de
prévision là dedans qui fait en sorte
que les gens super satisfait pas que ce
pétrole demeure aussi tu es pour
l'observer derniers jours donc on
reviendra vers d'autres éléments
hyvernat celtics qui vous passant très
important sur de l'organiser les mesures
d'incertitude dans les marchés et ces
mesures sont de l'ue sont relativement
stables depuis la dernière son bidon ça
donne un choix ou à 15h06 le vix qui les
indices de volatilité que les acteurs du
marché suivre de près merci monsieur
perrault pour cette analyse ce soir le
plaisir aussi